when quinn returned from vacation he
turned the heat back on in his home he
set the temperature as high as it could
go
q represents the temperature in quinn's
home in degrees celsius after t minutes
they say q is equal to 15 plus 0.4 t
what was the temperature when quinn
returned from vacation so pause this
video and see if you can work this out
on your own
all right so they want to know the
temperature and you might get a little
confused say hey maybe t is for
temperature no t is time in minutes
temperature
is q q represents the temperature so
they really want to know is what was q
when quinn returned from vacation well
right when quinn returned from vacation
that is when t is equal to zero so this
is equivalent to saying what is q our
temperature when zero minutes have
elapsed well if you go back to this
original equation we see that q is equal
to 15 plus
0.4 times the amount of elapsed time in
minutes so that's times zero so that's
just going to be 15 degrees celsius
if you're familiar with slope intercept
form you could think of it as our
temperature is equal to 0.4 times the
elapsed time
plus 15. so t equals zero you're left
with just this term which and off in
many cases we view as our y-intercept
what is going on right when we're just
getting started right when our
horizontal variable is equal to zero and
our horizontal variable in this
situation is elapsed time
how much does the temperature increase
every minute
there's a couple of ways you could think
about this one if you recognize this as
slope intercept form you could see that
0.4 is the slope so that says for a for
every one minute change in time you're
going to have an increase in temperature
by 0.4 degrees celsius so you could do
it that way
you could try out some values you could
say all right let me
think about what q is going to be based
on t so time t equals zero right when he
got home we already figured out that the
temperature is 15 degrees celsius
at t equals one what happens well it's
going to be 15 plus 0.4 times 1 well
that's just going to be 15.4 notice when
we increased
our time by 1 our temperature increased
by 0.4 degrees celsius by the slope and
it would happen again if we increased
time
by another minute if we go from 1 to 2
we would get to 15.8 we would increase
temperature by another
0.4 how much will the temperature
increase if quinn leaves the heat on for
20 minutes
pause the video and see if you can
answer that
all right now we have to be careful here
they're not asking us what is the
temperature after 20 minutes they're
saying how much will the temperature
increase if he leaves the heat on for 20
minutes if we just want to know what is
the temperature after 20 minutes we
would just say okay what is q when t is
equal to 20. so it'd be 15
plus 0.4 times 20 0.4 times 20 is 8 8
plus 15 is 23
so it's 23 degrees celsius after 20
minutes but that's not what they're
asking us they're asking how much will
the temperature increase well what did
we start from we started from 15 degrees
celsius and now after 20 minutes we have
gone to 23 degrees celsius so we have
increased by 8 degrees celsius or
another way to think about it we have
increased by this amount right over here
we started at 15 and after 20 minutes
we've increased by 0.4 times 20 which is
8 degrees celsius and we're done